un cereal que nutra el mundo entero el
trigo pero con la guerra en ucrania
estas espigas comienzan a acabarse en
algunas partes del mundo se comparte una
misma preocupación el riesgo de escasez
en los próximos meses rusia es el primer
país exportador a nivel mundial de trigo
ucrania el quinto entre los dos suman un
cuarto del comercio mundial desde el
comienzo de la guerra siete millones de
toneladas de trigo están a la espera en
dos principales puertos ucranianos el de
la asediada mariupol y sobre todo el de
odessa ley de bloque de hoy este trigo
está bloqueado en los campos ucranianos
pero también en los puertos hoy ningún
barco parte de ucrania entonces se
bloquea el flujo del comercio
internacional de los granos comienzan
tras nacional de guerra además para
moscú el trigo se ha vuelto imposible de
vender debido a las sanciones resultado
el precio aumenta
385 euros la tonelada un aumento de más
de 100 euros desde el comienzo del año
todos nos estamos enfrentando al aumento
de los precios pero también y sobre todo
estamos entrando en una crisis
alimentaria sin precedentes son gc de
una crisis alimentaria porque el trigo
se ha vuelto demasiado caro en países
como sudán somalia benin o incluso
indonesia ultra dependientes de los
stocks rusos y ucranianos unos como lyon
o turquía tienen reservas para algunas
semanas otros tienen suficiente para
aguantar algunos meses como egipto aún
así el gobierno intenta calmar a su
población con declaraciones como ésta
nuestro récord en los montos a fabril
ayer a partir de abril tendremos el
stock suficiente para llenar nuestras
demandas no será útil comprar sobre los
mercados antes del final del año 2022
y si dicen estoy en días porque hace 12
años la escasez de cereales causó un
estallido social en los países árabes y
del medio oriente
tenemos un aumento de los precios
entonces se avecinan tensiones sociales
durante las próximas semanas en estos
países fuertemente dependientes porque
la comida faltará la comida de base
faltará o se pondrá drásticamente más
cara
a pesar de la guerra los agricultores
ucranianos comenzaron a sembrar esta
semana con la esperanza de que en
algunos meses pueden recolectar
tranquilamente